this Ford Michigan Assembly Plant was
one of three factories where workers
walked off the job at midnight on
Thursday
some thirteen thousand members of the
United Auto Workers Union or the UAW are
on strike in three states one plant for
each of the big three car makers the
union which has 144 000 members says it
will add more plans to the strike if
negotiations don't progress when they're
making about billions of dollars in like
less than a year it's crazy these cars
are like 50 Grand 80 grand and we'd only
make that in a year
it was a theme developed by the UAW
president at a rally in downtown Detroit
in their economy
one of our workers would have to work
400 years to make what a CEO makes in
one year
so we're going to wreck their economy
because it only works for the
billionaire class
but the CEOs of the car makers say they
can't afford the uaw's demands and in
the end a strike will only hurt the
workers it's not going to be good for
the economy it's not going to be good
for anyone but you know specifically for
our people who work so hard and I'm
really proud of the GM manufacturing
team U.S President Joe Biden made a
televised statement on Friday reminding
the car companies that their record
profits a quarter of a trillion dollars
in the last 10 years were in part a
result of the concessions Auto Workers
made when the big three-phase bankruptcy
the companies have made some significant
offers but I believe they should go
further to ensure record corporate
profits mean record contracts for the
UAW said it again record corporate
profits which they have
should be shared by record contracts for
the UAW it's no secret that the White
House wants this strike to end as
quickly as possible but Biden needs to
act very carefully any suggestion that
he's leaning on the UAW leadership to
settle as quickly as possible as he has
done with other Union disputes over the
last few years will be taken very badly
by the rank and fail and Biden needs
this demographic in 2024 after all the
only one Michigan in 2020 by 155 000
votes
Detroit
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera